Now, I I like to tell people I don't
really consider myself
a particularly deep thinker,
but I'm a logical thinker. I think
logically. I think I got it from my dad
who was a mathematician.
And I think logically and it hit me that
if 1844 is wrong,
if this isn't true, then our church was
founded on a lie. Founded on a lie.
Founded on a lie.
It's as simple as that. It was. And I'm
going to touch on this a little more
tomorrow. So I'd realize if our church
arose from the the aftermath the
wreckage you want of the Millerite
movement based on our reinterpretation
of the 2300 days and I realized I said
I'm sorry if that is wrong then the
entire justification the entire
prophetic foundation of our church was
wrong. And I and so I said, either I get
it from the Bible
and the Bible alone
or I'm out of here.
Well, hey there.
Thank you for being here as always,
especially in a warm welcome if this is
your first time with us, Adventist or
otherwise.
As we just heard from Clifford
Goldstein, some of you may or may not
know who that is. If the Adventist
doctrinal novelty of the atonement is
false, so goes seventh day Adventism.
This really is the central pillar upon
which the entire House of Cards sits.
Not the Sabbath, not the law, but their
sanctuary system of redemption.
We're going to get into defining some of
those terms tonight because you may or
may not know what they mean by those
terms, but the investigative judgment is
only one of seven steps in their
sanctuary system of redemption.
Eventually, we will be doing a response
to all seven steps of their sanctuary
model, but tonight we're going to be
giving a theological beatdown to the
investigative judgment in particular. We
have uh had I don't know how many people
that constantly ask about biblical
arguments for any given theological
topic. Uh and so these sessions will be
focused on having all of those on one
topic in one place for you. Well, I
shouldn't say all of them. We're going
to look at 10 tonight. That is by no
means exhaustive, but 10 biblical
arguments that decimate this teaching.
Now, we aren't going to be listening and
responding to a sermon or talk like we
usually do. Instead, I will be
presenting numerous theological
reputations of the topic at hand. Like I
said, this is the first of many. We will
be starting with the investigative
judgment, which is what the SDA church
means when they use the word atonement.
You say, Miles, where are you getting
this from?
We have looked at this before but notice
this is from salvation contours of
avenotiology which is the most
up-to-date scholastic work from avenous
scholarship
on the subject of
redemption sotiology salvation an SDA
theologian John Pauline he writes quote
one of the most debated topics of
Christian theology is expressed in these
questions
why the cross What really happened at
the cross? The answers to these
questions have been widely debated under
the general heading of the atonement.
But when 7th Day Adventists approach the
matter of atonement, an immediate
dilemma is perceived.
When Adventists talk about atonement,
they refer specifically to what Jesus is
doing now in the heavenly sanctuary.
On the other hand, when scholars outside
the Seventh Day Adventist Church discuss
the atonement, they refer specifically
to the cross of Jesus Christ and what
God was doing there.
Close quote.
So when Adventists refer to the
atonement Christian, they mean what?
The investigative judgment.
We also read this in Walter Beach's uh
dimensions in salvation from 1963 which
is basically what salvation
uh contours of avenous sotiology is
basically just repeating but putting a
scholastic sort of verbiage to it. But
notice what he writes. Quote
atonement cannot be restricted to what
Christ accomplished on the cross. A
biblical view must include the
application of the benefits of the
sacrifice on the cross to the individual
sinner and the actualization of these
benefits in his life. Moreover, we
believe biblical atonement has yet wider
connotation, encompassing God's complete
work of salvation and restoration of his
creation to its original state. In this
larger total sense, atonement involves
in broad outline the issues and events
in the great controversy between Christ
and Satan.
Close quote.
So, as per usual, when the SDA church
talks about the atonement, like we've
seen before, it is defined in light of
their extra biblical paradigm, the great
controversy theme. And no, Adventists,
that's not just the belief that there's
a God and a Satan, a good and an evil.
They love to try and boil it down to,
"Oh, it's just" and then try and make it
seem like, "Oh, you're crazy for taking
umbrage with this. How could anybody
argue with this?" Yeah, because you're
generalizing it.
This whole cosmic narrative before the
Earth was created and all these events
that allegedly happened. You have to
have all that stuff. You can't just
Yeah, get out of here with that.
But beach as he and notice what he says.
He says it doesn't just encompass the
investigative judgment just like Dr.
Pauline says,
but it actually encompasses the entirety
of the great controversy and what the
adventist God is doing in vindicating
himself from Satan, which is what Beach
goes on to explain in this chapter.
If you are a Christian,
any former Adventist can tell you the
investigative judgment is one of the
most convoluted, complex theological
concepts ever imagined.
Which is why I'm going to do my best to
connect the dots as best I can without
belaboring the points. But this will
take some time. So be patient, track
with me, and take notes if necessary. I
always like to say for those that are
new, what you're about to hear is not
answering Adventism's private opinion,
interpretation, or ideas. I am a
messenger. I stand on the shoulders of
giants. And the goal of tonight is
multifaceted. It is to help Christians
and those coming out of Adventism
specifically since so many of them have
reached out to us better understand
where the issues are as well as to
demonstrate without question that this
doctrine is not only false but
completely contrary to both scripture,
history, and reason.
And I'm going to walk through 10
biblical reasons why. But before we get
into it,
I want to remind you all that if you
like what we are doing here, consider
becoming a channel member. You'll gain
access to our growing library of
membersonly content, including
membersonly live streams, the next of
which is tomorrow, and you will be
partnered with us in helping us fulfill
our mission to equip as many Christians
as possible to reach as many Seventh Day
Adventists as possible with the true
Christ and his gospel. You can click the
little join button down below this
video. You might have to be on a desktop
or you may not see it. Um, you can also
visit the link in the channel
description box. You can also visit our
channel homepage like you see on the
screen and you will see the same join
button in multiple places. Big shout out
to all of our members. This would not be
possible without you. All right. So, we
looked at what the SDA organization
means by the word atonement, but you
also need to understand what atonement
model they affirm.
What theory of the atonement do they
affirm? The organization claims to
uphold substitutionary atonement. This
is not to be confused with the
Protestant belief of penal
substitutionary atonement. And there is
a massive difference. So another scholar
that contributed to that book contours
of avenous sotiology.
Norman Gully notice what he wrote in a
paper for the Adventist Theological
Society some years ago regarding what
they mean by substitutionary atonement.
quote rightly used. The word
substitutionary in no way conotes that
Christ took our place in living a
perfect life so that we do not need to
be fitted for heaven aka sinless
perfectionism.
It need not conote this any more than it
conotes that he ascended to heaven in
our place. The word substitutionary
properly employed applies solely to
Christ taking our place at the cross,
doing for us what we could never do for
ourselves, that is perish in the second
death. Revelation 20:6, and still live
for eternity. In paying the price for
our sins, he alone could be our
substitute. This is the most glorious
good news, the wondrous exchange.
Close quote.
This is what he says. says the good news
is the gospel.
That's part of their message
that Jesus was a substitute only on the
cross in paying the penalty for death.
Remember what they mean when they use
the phrase fitted for heaven,
sinless perfectionism.
In the Adventist system, the Adventist
Jesus incarnated and came to earth as a
part of their great controversy
narrative. We don't have time to get
into all the specifics tonight on that.
I've done so exhaustively elsewhere,
both here and on our website. But part
of that narrative includes the claim
that prior to the earth's creation,
Satan began attacking the Ten
Commandments and claiming they can't be
kept.
So part of why the Adventist Jesus came
to Earth was to silence those
accusations by demonstrating they are
false, which is ultimately why he kept
the law perfectly. It vindicated the
law. It proved that what Satan was
saying was a lie and that no, it can't
be changed. it can't be altered, which
was one of these claims Satan was
allegedly making.
And this was to be an example to
humanity as well as all the other
watching intelligences in the universe
that they believe in that Satan's a
liar. The law can be kept when one
relies wholly on the power of the spirit
like Jesus did.
Because the Adventist worldview is
strictly physical, they do not have a
correct understanding of man's core
problem and issue.
In this model, sin is strictly
behavioral.
It is not something that is intrinsic to
one's fallen nature. Despite the
neoadventist, you know, branch of the
movement trying to adopt this aspect,
it's not at all compatible with that
model. So, they're inconsistent in doing
that.
But because it's strictly behavioral
in the actual worldview, in that in that
system, as long as you try really,
really, really hard and trust Jesus, you
can get to a totally sinless condition
in this life. Not only can you, but you
must
because it's your duty to do just like
Jesus did and silence Satan by keeping
the law perfectly and showing others it
can be done as well. This then
vindicates the Adventist God from
Satan's accusations, which Adventist
scholarship claims is the core focus of
the Adventist gospel.
So when they say Jesus was a substitute,
they only mean he paid the penalty for
sin, which is death. It does not include
that Jesus's perfectly sinless life and
record is credited to you, the believer,
such that God the Father sees you the
same way he does Jesus.
That's the classical Protestant teaching
in a nutshell.
That's not what they're saying when they
say substitutionary atonement.
Whenever the scriptures use the phrases
in Christ or in Christ Jesus and its
various iterations, these are terms of
union with Christ and representation.
Headship, something that's totally
foreign to Adventist theology.
God the Father sees all of those who are
in Christ as though they lived the life
that he lived. Which is why despite
still struggling with sin and in our war
with sin, the believer can rejoice that
Jesus is sufficient and enough.
Our shortcoming should actually point us
to Jesus.
And Adventists will often hear this and
think that if you disagree with their
belief, then you're somehow advocating
for living carnally. It's like, no,
nothing could be further from the truth.
But I say all that to say, you have to
understand these details to really
understand from the Adventist
perspective what role the teaching of
the investigative judgment plays. It is
step five out of their sevenstep
sanctuary model where Jesus is doing the
first of three phases of judgment.
The first phase dealing with all of
those who have professed faith in God
all the way back to Adam to the present
day and only those who have professed
faith.
That's a key component to this. by the
way, in refuting it. We'll talk about
that later.
The judgment of everyone else happens in
their theory in a second and third
phase, something we will cover at
another time. The third phase being
essentially the execution of what took
place in the second phase.
But in this investigative pre-advent
judgment, the claim is that Jesus is
investigating to see who out of these
professed believers is fit for heaven,
which is what we saw in Norman Gully
reference.
So essentially, the Adventist Jesus is
working on vindicating God in his
character. And to do that, there has to
be a people that are keeping the law
perfectly and silencing Satan like Jesus
did. That's supposedly what the
investigative judgment is for and to
show. You know, people will ask
questions. Well, are they saying that
Jesus is learning stuff? Well, no.
They're not going to tell you that. The
claim is going to be that it's for other
people that are looking in
because it's God having to vindicate
himself from Satan. All the angels are
standing in anticipation. You know, who
should we trust, God or Satan? And so
all this stuff in this sanctuary model
is about this the Adventist God having
to vindicate himself from that.
I mean this this is a God that is like
the the the gods that Elisha mocked.
It's like a a god like a man. But with
that backdrop filled in, let's read the
entirety of fundamental belief number 24
to hear how they present it. Then we
will begin our exposition.
quote,
"There is a sanctuary in heaven, the
true tabernacle that the Lord set up and
not humans."
By that they mean a physical building,
an architectural structure.
In it, Christ ministers on our behalf,
making available to believers the
benefits of his atoning sacrifice
offered once for all on the cross. At
his ascension, he was inaugurated as our
great high priest and began his
intercessory ministry which was typified
by the work of the high priest in the
holy place of the earthly sanctuary.
In 1844 at the end of the prophetic
period of 2300 days, he entered the
second and last phase of his atoning
ministry which was typified by the work
of the high priest in the most holy
place of the earthly sanctuary. It is a
work of investigative judgment which is
part of the ultimate disposition of all
sin.
So that's what I mean by it's one of the
steps in all these other steps
typified by the cleansing of the ancient
Hebrew sanctuary on the day of
atonement.
In that typical service, the sanctuary
was cleansed with the blood of animal
sacrifices, but the heavenly things are
purified with the perfect sacrifice of
the blood of Christ.
The investigative judgment reveals to
heavenly intelligences
who among the dead are asleep in Christ
and therefore in him are deemed worthy
to have part in the first resurrection.
It also makes manifest who among the
living are abiding in Christ, keeping
the commandments of God in the faith of
Jesus, and in him therefore are ready
for translation into his everlasting
kingdom.
This judgment vindicates the justice of
God in saving those who believe in
Jesus. It declares that those who have
remained loyal to God shall receive the
kingdom. The completion of this ministry
of Christ will mark the close of human
probation before the second advent.
and then all the supposed proof texts
that support this theory, many of which
we have dealt with on here before.
So, there is a lot in here, folks, a
lot. And it's a reminder of why
definitions matter. But let's begin our
10 reasons why the Bible refutes this.
Proof number one, according to the
Bible, Jesus was inaugurated as a priest
at his baptism, not the ascension.
This is to say that according to the
Bible, Jesus was inaugurated as a priest
before his ascension.
Now, the biblical evidence for this is
plentiful. For starters, the law
required that the day of atonement
sacrifice be offered up by who?
the high priest.
Well, the Adventist organization claims
that even though the antiypical day of
atonement started in 1844 and is
continuing to this day,
that the antiypical day of atonement
sacrifice took place at the cross.
Notice Leviticus 16 1-5.
The Lord spoke to Moses after the death
of the two sons of Aaron, when they drew
near before the Lord and died. And the
Lord said to Moses,
"Tell Aaron your brother not to come at
any time into the holy place inside the
veil, before the mercy seat that is on
the ark, so that he may not die. For I
will appear in the cloud over the mercy
seat." But in this way, Aaron shall come
into the holy place with a bull from the
herd for a sin offering, and a ram for a
burnt offering.
He shall put on the holy linen coat, and
shall have the linen undergarments on
his body. And he shall tie the linen
sash around his waist, and wear the
linen turban. These are the holy
garments. He shall bathe his body in
water, and then put them on.
and he shall take from the congregation
of the people of Israel two male goats
for a sin offering and one for a burnt
offering.
Thus the reading of God's holy word.
So this is from the chapter regarding
the day of atonement instructions and
requirements. And who were the
instructions given to?
The Levites, Aaron, Aaron and his
descendants which made up the Levitical
priesthood order.
And the law required that the day of
atonement sin offering be carried out by
the high priest, not just anyone. Which
would mean that Jesus, the true
fulfillment of the antiypical day of
atonement sacrifice, functioned as both
the offering and the priest that offered
it up. That was done at Calvary, which
is before the ascension. Secondly,
notice Hebrews 2 and then Romans 3.
Hebrews 2 and then Romans 3.
Since therefore
well halt, let me preface.
Before the author gets into this, he's
talking about why Jesus is superior to
the angels. This carries over from
chapter one,
but he starts off by laying out his case
at the beginning and in chapters two or
chapter chapters one and two that Jesus
is superior to anything in creation,
even the angels.
And then he ends this chapter by saying,
"Since therefore the children share in
flesh and blood, he himself likewise
partook of the same things, that through
death he might destroy the one who has
the power of death, that is the devil,
and deliver all those who through fear
of death were subject to lifelong
slavery. For surely it is not angels
that he helps, but he helps the
offspring of Abraham."
Therefore, he had to be made in his uh
brothers. He had to be made like his
brothers in every respect so that he
might become a merciful and faithful
high priest in the service of God to
make propitiation for the sins of the
people.
Thus the reading of God's holy word.
So at this part of the book of Hebrews
like I said the author is explaining how
Jesus did not come to save angels but
humans the offspring of Abraham. And
part of that included adding unto
himself a human nature. He had to be
human in order to offer up a true
atoning sacrifice for humans.
And before this paricopy in verses 10
through13,
the author quotes the Old Testament
which foretold of this that Jesus would
not be ashamed to be called our brother,
meaning adding unto himself a human
nature.
But in conjunction with all of that,
what does he say in verse 17?
that part of him adding unto himself
human nature was to become a high priest
in the service of God to what?
Make propitiation for the sins of the
people.
So catch that. He came in human likeness
not to help angels but humans. And part
of that included becoming a high priest
to make propitiation.
Well, when did Jesus make propitiation?
Because the text tells us that Jesus
made propitiation as a high priest.
So if propitiation occurred before the
ascension, this f this further
demonstrates Jesus was not inaugurated
to be a priest or a high priest at the
ascension but at a point before.
Well, Romans 3 tells us where
propitiation occurred.
I feel like we read this every week at
this point.
But I never tire of it.
But now the righteousness of God has
been manifested apart from the law.
Although the law and the prophets bear
witness to it,
the righteousness of God through faith
in Jesus Christ for all who believe. For
there's no distinction. For all have
sinned and fall short of the glory of
God, and are justified by his grace, as
a gift through the redemption that is in
Christ Jesus,
whom God put forward as a propitiation
by his blood to be received by faith.
This was to show God's righteousness
because in his divine forbearance, he
had passed over former sins. It was to
show his righteousness at the present
time so that he might be just and the
justifier of the one who has faith in
Jesus.
Thus, the reading of God's holy word.
Now, there's a lot here and we've looked
at this paricopy a number of times, like
I said, for various reasons. But when
does the text say that propitiation
occurred?
When Christ was put forth,
which was at Calvary.
Propitiation occurred at Calvary.
Which means Jesus functioned as both the
priest and the sacrifice at Calvary,
which is perfectly in line with what we
read in Leviticus as well as Hebrews 2.
Not just Hebrews 2, but the entire book,
more of which we're going to look at
later, a lot more of. But do a word
study, folks, on the Greek word for
propitiation. We just talked about this
last week with regards to the scapegoat.
It has to do with what the priest did
when he would sprinkle the blood on the
mercy seat in the day of atonement
ceremony.
And we also looked at last week how SDA
scholarship tries to make this work in
their model. So you can go and catch
that if you are curious. Spoiler alert,
it doesn't. The point being this further
evidences that Jesus functioned as a
priest prior to the ascension. The
ascension was Christ's coronation as a
king.
something their fundamental beliefs or
that fundamental belief says nothing
about. And we'll see why in a moment.
Christ at his ascension continues
in the execution of the office of priest
where he intercedes on behalf of his
people as the bridge between God and man
as the God man himself which we will see
in Hebrews 7 later is something he will
do forever. But that's one. Jesus was
not inaugurated to be a priest at the
ascension.
Proof two,
Jesus was not doing
not doing analogous work to the
Levitical priests in a holy place
apartment in heaven until 1844.
So the next part in the fund fundamental
belief attached to the claim that he was
inaugurated as a priest at his ascension
is the claim that Jesus began his
intercessory ministry which was typified
by the work of the high priest in the
holy place of the earthly sanctuary.
The wording of this is coming from Ellen
White who wrote this great controversy
page 428. Quote,
"In the service of the earthly
sanctuary, which as we have seen is a
figure of the service in the heavenly
when the high priest on the day of
atonement entered the most holy place,
the ministration in the first apartment
ceased."
God commanded, "There shall be no man in
the tabernacle of the congregation when
he goeth in to make an atonement in the
holy place until he comes out."
Leviticus 16:17. So when Jesus entered
the Holy of Holies to perform the
closing work of the atonement,
he ceased his ministration in the first
apartment.
But when the ministration in the first
apartment ended, the ministration in the
second apartment began.
When in the typical service, the high
priest left the holy on the day of
atonement, he went in before God to
present the blood of the sin offering in
behalf of all Israel who truly repented
of their sins. So Christ had only
completed one part of his work as our
intercessor to enter upon another
portion of the work and he still pleaded
his blood before the father in behalf of
sinners.
Close quote.
So here we see she claimed that between
the ascension and 1844, Jesus was only
in the outer apartment holy place of
this building in heaven doing analogous
work like the Levitical priest who daily
uh only ministered in that outer
apartment holy place.
Remember the most holy was only entered
once a year by the high priest on the
day of atonement. Then they would leave
and then come back the following year
repeat.
But the SDA church claims that is a
picture of what Jesus would do only in
heaven.
They don't claim he's he's performing
sacrifices up there and not that he
leaves and enters and leaves and enters
like on a yearly cycle. No, no, he only
entered into this building. Well, we'll
talk about some of the uh theories uh
later because there's varying theories
out there. There is the official
position which we'll talk about, but
there's other theories out there as well
that well, he did enter and then he left
and then he entered again later,
but they don't claim he's up there
performing sacrifices,
but that he's using his own blood from
his single sacrifice.
So, you have to get this if you're going
to understand what they're trying to say
here. In the Old Testament, the priest
would only enter the hol the most holy
place once a year. Outside of that, the
work was done outside in the outer
apartment for the daily work. But then
on the once once a year day of
atonement, the high priest would go into
the most holy place.
So they claim that's a picture of what
Jesus would do in the building in
heaven. That before 1844, Jesus was only
in the outer apartment.
And that work typified what Jesus would
be doing in this building in heaven. And
then in 1844 when the day of atonement
supposedly began, Jesus entered into the
most holy place to begin what that work
pictured.
And that's supposed to be a typology of
what's happening in the new covenant.
Understand the claim? All right. Here is
one of many reasons this is false.
First, notice what we're told in Hebrews
9 6-9.
Hebrews 9 6-9.
These preparations having thus been
made, the priests go regularly into the
first section, performing their ritual
duties. But into the second only the
high priest goes, and he but once a
year, and not without taking blood,
which he offers for himself, and for the
unintentional sins of the people.
By this the Holy Spirit indicates that
the way into the holy places is not yet
opened as long as the first section is
still standing
which is symbolic for the present age.
Thus the reading of God's holy word. All
right. So the author is talking about
the functions of the le uh Levitical
priests before he transitions to why
Jesus's priesthood is superior in the
next chapter. But notice verse eight and
then the scribal note which is included
in the verse in brackets in verse 9.
While the Levitical priests were doing
their work of dealing with sin, the way
into God's presence was closed off.
Only the high priest had access and only
once a year.
And while that work was continually
going on every year, every year it was a
constant reminder to the people of their
sin. as you can see in in Hebrews 10:3.
But in these sacrifices when he's
talking he goes back to talking about
the the Levitical priest there and in
talking about their sacrifices he says
they were a constant reminder of the
sins every year.
And then chapter 10 responds to this
where the author continues showing how
Jesus's priesthood and sacrifice is
better. We're told that the single
sacrifice of Christ one time perfected
for all time those that God is saving.
But also notice something else that's
mentioned in contrast to what we just
read in chapter uh 9.
Hebrews 10:1 19-22.
Therefore, brothers,
since we have confidence to enter the
holy places by the blood of Jesus, by
the new and living way that he opened
for us through the curtain, that is
through his flesh. And since we have a
great high priest over the house of God,
let us draw near with a true heart in
full assurance of faith, with our hearts
sprinkled clean from an evil conscience,
and our bodies washed with pure water.
And thus, the reading of God's holy
word. So, catch that. After telling us
the way for us to enter into the holy
places, the presence of God was closed
off
and only open to the priest, the high
priest, once a year.
We're then told a new and living way has
been opened for all believers,
not just the high priest, and not just
once a year.
And it's through the blood of Jesus, we
all have access to the blood of Christ,
not just a single high priest. And we
can all enter into the presence of God.
Well, what did Hebrews 9:8 say?
While the work of dealing with sin was
going on,
the way for God's people to enter before
him was closed.
Again, it was only open once a year to
the single high priest. And we were told
this remains the case while the work of
dealing with sin is going on.
But since we can enter in with boldness
now, that would mean that work is
finished and that barrier is no longer
standing. So Jesus was not doing the
analogous work of the Levitical priest
only in heaven for 1813 years in a holy
place outer apartment
or even after 1844 in a different
apartment which is what the SDA church
claims
because if Jesus were still dealing with
sin the way for us wouldn't be opened.
That's what separated them from from
God. They couldn't approach and enter
in. And that's why even the priest had
to offer up a sin offering for himself,
cleanse himself before he could enter
into the presence of God, which we're
going to look at later.
But this is also why unlike in the old,
a person's conscience can now be
cleaned. It was never cleansed with the
sacrifice of bulls and goats. The
constant work of dealing with sin
reminded them that they would be back
with sac to sacrifice more animals for
their sin. But Jesus's single sacrifice
perfectly perfects those it is presented
before the father for which is why he
can bold uh that which is why we can
boldly approach God with assurance.
So unless the book of Hebrews is written
after 1844, this refutes that claim.
This is an issue of Ellen White as well
as the SDA pioneers not understanding
the two apartment system being a symbol
of this age and the age to come. a
constant a contrast
between Judaism of old and Christianity
of new. Two distinct priesthoods, Aaron
and MelkiseDC.
For Adventism, the two compartments
represent a two-phaseed ministry of
Jesus
that for 1813 years he did one phase and
then in 1844 entered the other apartment
to begin a new phase
or rather he continued after at the
ascension. He he continued
and then entered the second phase in
1844.
But that's not what the the that's not
what the the the compartments were
representative of.
Yet their mentality was that they're
here, you know, God raised them up to
correct everyone else on what the
priesthood of Jesus looks like.
The issue isn't the old covenant
priesthood work. It was these SDA
pioneers twisting of the text and trying
to draw out a parallel that breaks down.
So that's proof too. Jesus was not doing
the equivalent of the earthly holy place
ministry only up in heaven until 1844
in an apartment building
analogous to the Levitical priest.
Proof three, which piggybacks off of
that.
Blood was not taken into the holy place
daily for individual penitent
Israelites.
Blood was not taken into the holy place
daily for individual penitent
Israelites.
Again, they rely on the Old Testament
type to try and claim we live in the
antityypical day of atonement. The claim
being that in the old covenant,
individual penitent Israelites would
bring their sacrifices daily for their
sin and the priest would slaughter it
upon the person confessing their sin.
They then claimed this transferred the
person's sin in type to the animal and
the blood was then taken by the priest
into the holy place and sprinkled before
the veil.
This transference of blood then
transfers the person's sin into the
sanctuary and it rested in front of the
veil of the most holy place to await
being dealt with on the day of atonement
when the sanctuary itself was cleansed.
So make sure you got that because this
is what they try and say pictures for us
what the current day we live in is like.
You come to Jesus the high priest,
confess your sin, and in type it's
transferred to the heavenly sanctuary to
be dealt with during this day of
atonement period, which is 1844 till
whenever probation closes and Jesus
stops being a priest.
Notice again what Ellen White says from
patriarchs and prophets.
Quote,
"The most important part of the daily
ministration was the service performed
in behalf of who?
individuals.
The repentant sinner
brought his offering to the door of the
tabernacle and placing his hand upon the
victim's head, confessed his sins, thus
in figure transferring them from himself
to the innocent sacrifice.
by his own hand, the animal was then
slain. And the blood was carried by the
priest
into the holy place and sprinkled before
the veil behind which the ark containing
the law that the sinner had
transgressed.
By this ceremony, the sin was through
the blood transferred in figure to the
sanctuary.
In some cases, the blood was not taken
into the holy place, but the flesh was
then to be eaten by the priest, as Moses
directed the sons of Aaron, saying, "God
hath given it to you. Bear the iniquity
of the congregation." Leviticus 10:17.
Both ceremonies alike symbolized the
transfer of sin from the penitant to the
sanctuary.
Close quote.
So for starters,
scripture nowhere describes blood as a
transference mechanism. Nowhere.
This is assumed to be what took place by
them.
But the text nowhere says this.
But notice she said the most important
part of what ministry?
The daily,
the daily ministration for who?
Individuals,
individual penitent Israelites.
And when they would bring a sacrifice,
their sin was transferred or or sorry,
their sin was transferred to the animal
upon confession and laying on of hands
and then through the animal's blood
transferred into the holy place to be
sprinkled before the veil where it would
rest until the cleansing of the
sanctuary on the day of atonement. Yeah,
this contradicts scripture. Blood was
only ever taken into the sanctuary on
two occasions outside of the day of
atonement. Notice what they are.
Leviticus 4 is what lays this out.
The first instance we find is in
Leviticus 4 1-6.
And the Lord spoke to Moses, saying,
"Speak to the people of Israel, saying,
'If anyone sins unintentionally
in any of the Lord's commandments about
things not to be done and does any one
of them, if it is the appointed priest
who sins,
thus bringing guilt on the people,
then he shall offer for the sin that he
has committed a bull from the herd
without blemish to the Lord for a sin
offering."
He shall bring the bowl to the entrance
of the tent of meeting before the Lord
and lay his hand on the head of the bull
and kill the bull before the Lord. And
the anointed priest shall take some of
the blood and the bowl and bring it into
the tent of meeting. And the priest
shall dip his finger in the blood and
sprinkle part of the blood seven times
before the Lord in front of the veil of
the sanctuary.
Thus the reading of God's holy word.
So if the priest sinned
then this process was to be followed and
the blood of the sacrifice was to be
taken into the sanctuary.
The second is later in the same chapter
Leviticus 4:13-17.
If the whole congregation of Israel sins
unintentionally and the thing is hidden
from the eyes of the assembly
and they do any one of the things that
by the Lord's commandments ought not to
be done and they realize their guilt
when the sin which they have committed
becomes known, the assembly shall offer
a bull from the herd for a sin offering
and bring it in front of the tent of
meeting and the elders of the
congregation shall lay their hands on
the head of the bull before the Lord.
ward and the bull shall be killed before
the Lord.
Then the appointed priest shall bring
some of the blood of the bull into the
tent of meeting and the priest shall dip
his finger in the blood and sprinkle it
seven times before the Lord in front of
the veil.
Thus the reading of God's holy word. So
the second was if the entire Israelite
nation sinned unintentionally and
realized their guilt,
then this process was to be carried out
and the blood from the sacrifice brought
into the sanctuary and sprinkled before
the veil.
But neither of these two instances were
the daily ministration for individual
penitent Israelites.
The same chapter lays out what was
supposed to happen in that instance and
the blood was never brought into the
sanctuary.
Adventists will try and appeal to these
texts to make them work for their type
antitype. We just saw that last week
actually,
but these aren't referring to the daily
ministration for individual penitent
Israelites.
Furthermore, scripture nowhere describes
blood as a transference vehicle for sin.
that it's that it was used to, you know,
as a vehicle to move sin around to
different places. It's like this is so
ingrained in SDA theology that it's
almost taken for granted. Yet, it's not
biblical.
Blood is always described as purifying,
cleansing, forgiving, renewing,
never transferring
again. And they make that error like we
saw last week with the scapegoat.
But that's proof three which undermines
their entire framework and model. Blood
was never taken into the sanctuary
during the daily ministration for
individual penitent Israelites.
Proof number four. Sin was put away at
the cross.
Sin was put away at the cross.
This is actually going to be a two for
one with a bonus point added on.
Hebrews 9, folks, is what I like to call
a theological powerhouse in the Bible.
It is saturated with so much rich
theology. And in order to grasp what all
is being said, understanding the Old
Testament, specifically the Levitical
priesthood work, is an absolute must.
The writer of this book was writing to a
predominantly Jewish convert audience,
an audience that would have been very
familiar with that Old Testament and the
Levitical law work. And in chapter 9,
he's in the middle of explaining what
makes Jesus's priesthood superior to
that of the Levites. And part of that
includes the once single sacrifice of
Christ for all time that never needs
repeated because it puts sin away at the
cross and is able to perfect the person
it was made for cleansing the person's
conscience which was something animal
sacrifices could not do.
Animal sacrifices we are told were a
constant reminder of sin because the
person knew there would be more to come
even after the once a year day of
atonement ceremony.
But in the flow of the presentation,
Hebrews 9:19-26,
he writes,
"For when every commandment of the law
had been declared by Moses to all the
people, he took the blood of calavs and
goats with water and scarlet wool and
hissup and sprinkled both the book
itself and all the people,
saying, "This is the blood of the
covenant that God commanded for you."
And in the same way, he sprinkled with
the blood both the tent and all the
vessels used in worship.
Indeed, under the law, almost everything
is purified with blood. And without the
shedding of blood, there is no
forgiveness of sins.
Whoops. Sorry,
I didn't realize that my slide there
didn't have the earlier verses on it.
That was 19-22.
Thus it was necessary for the copies of
the heavenly things to be purified with
these rights, but the heavenly things
themselves with better sacrifices than
these. For Christ has entered not into
holy places made with hands, which are
copies of the true things, but into
heaven itself.
Now to appear in the presence of God on
our behalf. Nor was it to offer himself
repeatedly as the high priest enters the
holy places every year with blood not
his own. For then he would have had to
have suffered repeatedly since the
foundation of the world. But as it is,
he has appeared once for all at the end
of the ages to put away sin by the
sacrifice of himself.
Thus the reading of God's holy word.
So this is after he has explained that a
new covenant was inaugurated on better
promises than that which instituted uh
was instituted with Moses.
what was enacted with Moses was simply a
type that pointed to a greater
fulfillment, namely the new covenant.
He also explains that the Mosaic
covenant was inaugurated with blood. You
can read about that in Exodus obviously.
And everything was then sprinkled um
with that blood signifying its
ratification. So the book of the law was
sprinkled, all the furniture, all that
stuff.
This is because without the shedding of
blood, there's no forgiveness of sins.
Then verse 23 begins a pivot back to the
greater
which the old shadow pointed to.
We are told that it was also necessary
for the reality of what that earthly
sanctuary pointed to to also be purified
by those rights. However, it was better
sacrifices plural than those earthly
animal sacrifices. If you remember the
fundamental belief on this,
they try and cite this, but they say the
sacrifice of Christ singular. This is
why I always bring up as well like last
week,
Jesus is all of the laws, sacrifices,
and offerings in one.
Sacrifices plural.
But when verse 20 uh in verse 24, we're
told that Jesus didn't enter into a
building like what was on earth, an
architectural structure made with hands,
which were, you know, was only a picture
or a type. But Jesus entered into heaven
itself to appear in the presence of God
on behalf of his people.
Notice what Charles Haden Spurgeon says
about this in his uh Metropolitan
Tabernacle sermons. So he was preaching
on this chapter and he says, quote,
"There's a true house of God, a real
temple of the infinite, a living abode
of the Godhead."
The epistle to the Hebrews speaks of the
true tabernacle, which the Lord pitched
in not man.
There is still a trusting place where
God doth meet with man and hold
fellowship with him. That place is the
person of the Lord Jesus Christ, in whom
dwelleth the fullness of the Godhead
bodily. The manhood of Christ is become
to us the antitype of that tent in the
center of the camp.
God is in Christ Jesus. Christ Jesus is
God. And in his blessed person, God
dwells in the midst of us as in a tent.
For such is the force of the original in
our text. The word was made flesh and
tabernacled or tented among us.
That is to say, in Christ Jesus, the
Lord dwelt among man, as God of old,
dwell in his sanctuary in the midst of
the tribes of Israel.
This is very delightful and hopeful for
us. The Lord God doth dwell among us
through the incarnation of his son, but
the substance far excels the shadow. For
in the wilderness the Lord only dwelt in
the abode of man, but now
his approaches to us is closer, for he
dwells in the flesh of man. Close quote.
It all points to Jesus, my friend. All
of it, including the physical tabernacle
where God's presence dwelt. Jesus is
that tabernacle amongst us like the
physical building was. And he entered
into heaven itself where the manifest
presence of God dwells.
But that issue aside, the Levitical
priests also entered into the presence
of God, but only the high priest and
only once a year.
The author has already told us that
previously in the chapter, like we saw
in Hebrews 9:7, the high priest entered
into the presence of God, but only once
a year, not without blood. But what did
that Levitical priest have to do before
he could enter into the presence of God?
He had to make atonement for himself and
his household.
This was because he was a sin-laden
sinner. He could not enter into God's
presence without being cleansed and
pure.
So remember that in light of what the
author says next, verse 25.
Jesus didn't enter into heaven itself to
offer repetitive sacrifices like the
Levitical priest did. If this were the
case, then he would have had to have
suffered repeatedly for the rest of
time. Instead,
he entered into the presence of God one
single time after putting sin away at
the cross.
Why is the author saying this here?
The Levitical priest engaged in
repetitious sacrifices.
And even on the once a year day of
atonement, he knew that he would be back
the following year because the blood of
bulls and goats was not sufficient.
Jesus is the opposite of this.
Yet notice what he said about sin being
put away at the cross.
Again, we have to ask why is the author
saying this here?
Well, just like the earthly priest was
covered in sin as a sinner,
so too Jesus became such.
1 Peter 2:24 says that he bore our sins
in his body on the tree. Uh Isaiah 53
says that God the Father laid on him the
iniquity of us all and he was crushed
and bruised for those. In 2 Corinthians
5, we're told that he who knew no sin
became sin so that we might become the
righteousness of God.
So on the cross, Jesus was covered in
sin despite not being a sinner himself.
And just like the earthly priest had to
put that sin away before he could enter
into God's presence, so too, Christ had
to put the sin that was placed on him
away before he entered into his rightful
state and entered back into the presence
of God as the God man to mediate for his
people.
This is not at all compatible with the
investigative judgment and sanctuary
model. They claim that Jesus transferred
sin by means of his blood up into a
building in heaven
for it to rest on record. Then in 1844,
he would begin investigating the books
that record this sin and start dealing
with blotting it out then, which would
mean the sin is there in the presence of
God.
for a movement that claims to have
mastered the Old Testament, specifically
the Day of Atonement in Leviticus 16.
Yeah, this is strong evidence that this
is not the case. Now, the bonus point
that I mentioned
earlier,
Hebrews 9:22
said that without the shedding of blood,
there's no forgiveness of sin.
Now, one must tread carefully here and
pay close attention because one could
point out that there were bloodless
atoning sacrifices under the law, such
as Leviticus 5 11-13,
which was a grain offering.
God told Israel that if they couldn't
afford two pigeons or two turtle doves,
then a tenth of an ea of fine flour
could be substituted.
So, does that mean the author didn't
know what he was talking about and that,
well, the shedding of blood wasn't
required for the forgiveness of sins?
Of course not.
Because in the day of atonement
ceremony, blood was offered for the sins
of the entire nation.
All of the cleansing rights of the old
covenant, like the bloodless grain
offering, were subsumed under the
absolute necessity of a blood sacrifice
once every year. So while the grain
offerings could atone for sin in some
cases,
they were only effectual because of this
annual event which included sacrifice.
Make sense?
Since this is the case, the SDA model
has a serious problem.
They claim that the antityypical day of
atonement began on October 22nd, 1844
when Jesus started the investigative
judgment. But they also say that the
antityypical day of atonement sacrifice
took place at Calvary almost 2,000 years
before this antityypical day of
atonement actually began.
So they have this massive gap in between
when the sacrifice itself took place and
when the actual antitypical day of
atonement work began.
In this work starting in 1844, they
claim that Jesus began the process of
remitting sins. But how can that happen
if Jesus isn't in heaven shedding his
blood?
Without the shedding of blood, there's
no forgiveness of sins.
Scriptur is clear that Jesus only shed
his blood one time, and we just read the
instance of this. So, on the one hand,
they claim he didn't remit sins when he
actually shed his blood, but began doing
so almost 2,000 years removed from that
in a new event that he started where he
isn't actually shedding his blood. Makes
total sense, right? Yeah. Clear as mud.
But that's proof four. Jesus put sin
away at the cross.
He isn't dealing with it in heaven
still.
And this was absolutely necessary
because he had to put it away before he
could enter into the presence of God.
On top of that, he isn't shedding his
blood in heaven, which means he can't be
dealing with the removal of sin like
they claim he currently is.
Proof five,
simple and quick. If sin was put away at
the cross, the scapegoat can't be Satan.
And yes, that refutes the investigative
judgment because they need that to be
true for this whole chain to work.
So in conjunction with proof four, this
is a death blow to the investigative
judgment
because you can't have the rest of the
framework without it. They have to have
this as a link in their chain of events,
otherwise the system breaks. Now, I've
already demonstrated this exhaustively
elsewhere, such as last week, so you can
go and check that out for more in-depth
analysis on this one.
Proof six, Jesus is seated on his
throne, signifying that the work of
dealing with sin is finished.
All throughout Hebrews as well as
elsewhere
like the book of Acts,
the biblical writers go to great lengths
to talk about Jesus being seated on his
throne.
Again, the original audience of the
Hebrews understood the Old Testament
very well.
And when they would have heard this,
they would have understood how stark a
contrast this was to the Levites.
For starters, the Levites were not
kings.
There was no throne for them to sit on
in the tabernacle, though the mercy seat
is the equivalent of such because God's
manifest presence, but it wasn't for
them to sit on in the tabernacle. And
they never sat down because their work
of dealing with sin was forever ongoing.
In Hebrews 10 8-14,
the author gives us a picture of this
complete uh you know or or gives us a a
a picture of this compare and contrast.
Notice
when he said above, you have neither
desired nor taken pleasure in sacrifices
and offerings and burnt offerings and
sin offerings. These are offered
according to the law. Then he added,
"Behold, I have come to do your will."
He does away with the first in order to
establish the second. And by that will,
we have been sanctified through the
offering of the body of Jesus Christ
once for all.
Ah, the difference between experiential
and positional sanctification, another
topic we're going to talk about in the
coming weeks.
And every priest stands daily at his
service, offering repeatedly the same
sacrifices, which can never take away
sins.
But when Christ had offered for all time
a single sacrifice for sins, he sat down
at the right hand of God, waiting from
that time until his enemies should be
made a foottool for his feet.
For by a single offering he has
perfected for all time those who are
being sanctified.
Thus the reading of God's holy word.
Notice Christ had offered for all time a
single sacrifice for sins.
And in doing so
we've been sanctified.
Goes on to say those who are being
sanctified. Again, we will talk about
progress or uh experiential and
positional sanctification in another
night.
But the author tells us it was not God's
plan
for sacrifice to take place indefinitely
for the rest of existence.
And God did away with the first co
covenant, abregating it by inaugurating
the new. And remember in the previous
chapter, he went through this already.
Some of which we saw earlier. This was
done by the once-foralltime single
sacrifice of Christ. Then verse 11, what
does he say
that the Levitical priests stood daily
at his office
which was the work of dealing with sin.
That was their job. And they did so by
repeatedly offering sacrifices for sin
which could never actually take it away.
But unlike them, Christ offered himself
one time, actually put sin away at the
cross, like we just saw in Hebrews 9:26,
and then did what?
Entered into the presence of God and sat
down at the right hand of God, where he
will remain until all of his enemies are
made a foottool.
And his single sacrifice actually
perfects all of those for whom it was
made, which are the individuals that God
is presently sanctifying by the power of
the Holy Spirit.
This is what Christ is presently doing,
folks.
He is ruling and reigning as a priest
king because Hebrews 7:1 says that
Melkisedc was both a priest and a king
simultaneously.
The Levites were only priests, which is
why they didn't have a throne to sit on.
It is very telling that the SDA
fundamental belief number 24 on the
investigative judgment in the sanctuary
says absolutely nothing about the
kingship of Christ.
And this is because they don't teach
he's actually functioning as a king
right now, ruling and reigning over his
kingdom. We have looked at this before
and listened to numerous SDA figures
talk about this and we have seen how
they say he will receive his kingdom
after the investigative judgment is
complete because Jesus's kingdom is the
people that make it up, not territorial.
And since the investigative judgment is
where it is being determined who is and
isn't fit for his kingdom, something
else we saw earlier, Jesus isn't
actually functioning as a king right
now. This ultimately is coming from a
vision from Ellen White, something else
we've looked at numerous times where she
claims in the future he will cease being
a priest, taking off his priestly
garments and putting on his kingly ones.
But no, they have it totally backwards.
Christ is simultaneously a priest and a
king right now.
The fact that he is seated represents
the fact that he isn't still dealing
with sin anymore like the the Levitical
priests who were always standing.
On top of this, if an Adventist wants to
make the argument that what was on earth
was identical to what is in heaven, only
what was on earth was a scaled down
version, then they need to provide an
example for us where there was a throne
for the Levites to sit on.
Not just that, but based on Ellen
White's alleged vision, there's
apparently two thrones with one in the
holy place, outer apartment.
Then they got up off the throne and
moved into the holy place. Yeah. Yeah.
That doesn't sound like it was identical
to what was on earth, but that's proof
six. Jesus is seated as a priest king
and is presently making all of his
enemies his foottool as he rules and
reigns with all authority in heaven and
on earth. He's not dealing with sin
anymore. let alone did he begin
expedating it in 1844.
Proof number seven, Jesus is an eternal
priest king.
Jesus is an eternal priest king.
In our world today, folks, this is
something people really need to
understand. And Christians really need
to understand this because if you
understand what Christ's role currently
is right now,
it'll give you a lot better perspective
on our at least if you're in the west. I
can't speak to what's going on in the
east that that that well right now, but
if you're in the west today and you're a
Christian, this reality, this truth
should bring you great joy and hope.
But in conjunction with proof five,
scripture teaches that Jesus will
forever be a priest king,
which evidences that the SDA
understanding of what the priestly work
of Christ in heaven looks like is badly
skewed.
Hebrews 7 and the Psalms, which the
author of Hebrews cites, is crystal
clear on this.
I I don't know if there is any further
of a thus plain thus sayeth the Lord in
all of scripture.
It's like so much so it's almost hard to
believe the SDA church tries claiming
this still.
But again, alleged visions from Ellen
White confirm this. So they're stuck
having to try and defend it.
First we will look at the biblical
witness and then we will look at the
supposed vision.
Hebrews 7 11-25.
Little bit of reading here, but pay very
close attention.
Now, if perfection had been attainable
through the Levitical priesthood, for
under it the people received the law,
what further need would there have been
for another priest to arise after the
order of MelkiseDC rather than one named
after the order of Aaron?
For when there is a change in the
priesthood, there is necessarily a
change in the law as well.
For the one of whom these things are
spoken belong to another tribe from
which no one has ever served at the
altar. For it is evident that our Lord
was descended from Judah. And in
connection with that tribe, Moses said
nothing about priests.
This becomes even more evident when
another priest arises in the likeness of
MelkiseDC who has become a priest not on
the basis of a legal requirement
concerning bodily descent but by the
power of an indestructible
life.
For it is witnessed of him, you are a
priest
forever after the order of Melkisedc.
For on the one hand, a former
commandment is set aside because of its
weakness and uselessness, for the law
made nothing perfect. But on the other
hand, a better hope is introduced
through which we draw near to God.
And it was not without an oath. For
those who formerly became priests were
made such without an oath, but this one
was made a priest with an oath by the
one who said to him,
"The Lord has sworn and will not change
his mind,
you are a priest forever."
This makes Jesus the guarantor of a
better covenant.
The former priests were many in number
because they were prevented by death
from continuing in office.
But he holds his priesthood permanently
because he continues forever.
Consequently, he is able to save to the
uttermost those who draw near to God
through him since he always lives
always lives to make intercession for
them.
And thus the reading of God's holy word.
Folks, it really does not get much more
plain than that.
Unlike the Levitical priests who were
many in number because they would
eventually die, Jesus holds his office
permanently because of his
indestructible life.
He then cites Psalm 110 which is a
messianic psalm about Jesus where it was
foretold that Jesus is a priest for how
long after the order of Melkisedc?
Forever.
And again, 71 already told us that
MelkiseDC was both a priest and a king
simultaneously. That's the office that
Jesus will hold forever. And it's part
of what makes the new covenant better.
Jesus forever lives to make intercession
for his people.
As the God man, he bridged the gap
between man and God. And he will forever
be the God man
and forever even into eternity intercede
for us by keeping us in union with him
forever.
That's why he is able to save to the
uttermost perfectly.
I don't think the author could have said
it any more times than he did there.
Forever. Forever. Permanently.
You have sworn
your mind will not change. Talking about
God the Father speaking to the Son.
You're a priest forever.
And that's an oath unbreakable by the
Almighty himself.
Well, notice now what the Adventist
prophetus had to say about this and how
she botches it.
Quote,
"About 4 months since, I had a vision of
events all in the future,
and I saw the time of trouble such as
never was."
Jesus told me it was the time of Jacob's
trouble, and that we should be delivered
out of it by the voice of God. Just
before we entered it, we all received
the seal of the living God.
Then I saw the four angels cease to hold
the four winds. And I saw famine,
pestilence, and sword. Nation rose
against nation, and the whole world was
in confusion.
Then we cried to God for deliverance day
and night, till we began to hear the
bells of Jesus's garment.
And I saw Jesus rise up in the holiest.
And as he came out, we heard the
tinkling of bells and knew our high
priest was coming out.
Then we heard the voice of God which
spoke the heavens or or which shook the
heavens and earth and gave the 144,000
the day and hour of Jesus's coming.
Then the saints were free united and
full of the glory of God. For he had
turned their captivity. And I saw a
flaming cloud come where Jesus stood.
And he laid off his priestly garment and
put on his kingly robe. took his place
on the cloud which carried him to the
east where it first appeared to the
saints on earth a small black cloud
which was the sign of the son of man.
While the cloud was passing from the
holiest to the east which took a number
of days the synagogue of Satan worshiped
at the saints feet.
Close quote.
So she claims to have had a vision of
future events,
namely the time of trouble. For those
unaware, this was also a time when it
was present truth to believe that the
time of trouble was about to begin.
Visions like this one being used to
bolster this narrative. But in this
vision, she allegedly saw Jesus rise up
off his throne,
which was indicated by the tinkling on
the hem of his garments.
Yes, this is because she claimed
elsewhere he was wearing Levitical
priesthood garments, despite Exodus
telling us those were distinct to Aaron
and the Levites.
They were then told the day and the hour
of Jesus's return
with the belief being that they, the
present group, were a part of the
144,000.
This entire time she's using inclusive
pronouns, we, us, etc., including
herself into the group. They obviously
pivoted on this
like tons of other doctrines. But amidst
this,
she then says, "A flaming cloud
approached the Adventist Jesus's feet
after he stood up and he did what?
Took off his priestly garment and put on
his kingly robe."
We've looked at it before, but SDA
scholar and professor Roy Ga has written
on this where he says it's not literal
garments that he changes. He isn't
literally wearing Levitical priesthood
garments. This was just representative
for Ellen White to let her see Jesus's
change in function.
The priestly garments just represented
his work as a priest. The kingly
garments represent the assumption of the
role of king,
which is exactly what they teach
theologically, that Jesus will cease
being a priest after the investigative
judgment finishes, probation will close,
the time of trouble will begin, and it
will last roughly 7 days because Ellen
White also claimed that it will take
them 7 days to get here according to the
book of Revelation.
Notice Christ in his sanctuary, page
153.
quote, "Those who are living upon the
earth when the intercession of Christ
shall cease in the sanctuary above are
to stand in the sight of a holy God
without a mediator. Their robes must be
spotless. Their characters must be
purified from sin by the sprinkling of
blood
through the grace of God and their own
diligent effort. They must be conquerors
in the battle with evil. While the
investigative judgment is going forward
in heaven, while the sins of penitent
believers are being removed from the
sanctuary, there is to be a special work
of purification of putting away of sin
among God's people upon the earth. This
work is more closely presented or
clearly presented in the messages of
Revelation 14. Close quote. Yeah, this
flagrantly contradicts Hebrews 7 and
shows a fundamental ignorance around
both the nature of Christ as well as his
function.
During the time of trouble, Adventism
claims you'll have to have gotten to a
totally sinless condition or you won't
make it. Satan will get you. We've
looked at that quote from Great
Controversy a lot of times as well.
Or she says, "This is the condition that
you must be in if you want to make it
through the time of trouble after
explaining Jesus in the wilderness and
that Satan could find absolutely no sin
in him.
So unless you are perfectly sinless as
Jesus was, you're not going to make it."
and Jesus will have ceased mediating for
you, which elsewhere in this book, she
claims he's actually only mediating for
those that believe this teaching. Those
who hear about it and see all of the
holes and fallacies,
they are said to be willingly ignorant
of the work that Jesus is currently
doing and he and they can't be benefited
thereof.
But that's proof seven. Jesus is seated
on his throne, signifying that the work
of dealing with sin is finished already.
Ellen White and Adventism have him
seated on various thrones in various
compartments in a building in heaven
where he's still dealing with sin from a
seated position with the sin in the
presence of God and he ceases being a
priest.
Proof number eight,
Jesus entered into the equivalent of the
earthly most holy place at his
ascension, not in 1844.
Hebrews 6:1 19-20 is not only the select
text chosen for this ministry, but they
have a longstanding history for the SDA
church.
First, let's read it and then get into
their arguments and why they are dead on
arrival.
We have this as a sure and steadfast
anchor of the soul, a hope that enters
into the inner place behind the curtain
where Jesus has gone as a forerunner on
our behalf, having become a high priest
forever after the order of MelkiseDC.
and thus the reading of God's holy word.
So I just want to point out again the
author tells us Jesus is a priest
forever. So add that to the list for
proof number seven.
But this is the author's segue into
chapter 7 where he begins describing the
Melkisedcian priesthood.
And Adventists take umbrage with the
phrase within the veil or some will
render it behind the curtain.
They have issues with this referring to
the equivalent of the most holy place.
I don't have time to get into all of the
back and forth on that, but these are
some of the most contested verses by the
SDA church,
which really came to a head with Desmond
Ford and his dissenting work on the
subject.
But from the earliest days of the
movement, people like OL Croer were
putting forth theories on this passage
to try and make it fit with 1844
theology.
This is what the major arguments have
been for their view regarding this verse
or these verses.
One that the tabernacle had two veils
and the one that separated the holy
place from the courtyard is what's in
focus. And they try and use Hebrews 9:3
where it's giving the layout of the
furniture in the earthly sanctuary. And
they try and say that's what's in
reference when it talks about there
being a second veil. See, there were two
veils. So that's what's in reference in
619.
Another is the same Hebrew word and the
same Greek word are applied to both
curtains. That was Uriah Smith's
argument.
So Smith argued on the basis of this
that because the word veil in the Old
Testament is ambivalent, we can't say
with specificity that within the veil in
619-20 is referring to the equivalent of
the second veil into the most holy
place.
And we've looked at some modern SDA
scholarship on here before who embrace
this position and argument. But then you
have EE Andros who wrote an apologetic
response to AF Ballinger who left
Adventism. He argued that within the
veil does indeed refer to the most holy
place and Jesus entered there at his
ascension. But
this was only momentarily
and this is what I was referring to
earlier.
I've recently heard a number of SDA
pastors that are beginning to embrace
this position.
They appeal like Andros did to Hebrews
9:21
and say Jesus had to go into the most
holy place temporarily to activate the
temple by dedicating his blood.
Then following this event, he left back
to the outer apartment to do that work
until 1844 and then he returned back
into the most holy place.
But then the fourth is
WW Fletcher in 1925 put forth the
defense that in addition to Hebrews 9:3
and the second veil argument, the inner
veil of the most holy place is qualified
with the term second veil.
Then he would appeal to numbers 18:7
where the phrase within the veil is used
to generally refer to the sanctuary as a
whole. So he tried interpreting the text
to be saying that Jesus entered into the
sanctuary building generally
but the text doesn't specify enough
about which veil was entered
bro left the SDA church in 1930 by the
way
and most importantly the SDA prophetus
an alleged stamp of approval you know
directly from God claiming the simple
declaration that Croer put forth
that it refers to the one that separated
the courtyard from the holy place. This
is from an article by Roy Ga in Ministry
magazine December 1983 where he quotes
Ellen White, but notice what he says.
Quote, Ellen White uses Hebrews 6:19-20
to refer to Christ's passage through the
first veil
and the consequent commencement of his
holy place ministry.
Then he quotes her. The ministration of
the priest throughout the year in the
first apartment of the sanctuary within
the veil which formed the door and
separated the holy place from the outer
court represents the work of
ministration upon which Christ entered
at his ascension. It was that uh it was
the work of the priest in the daily
ministration to present before God the
blood of the sin offering also the
incense which ascended with the prayers
of Israel. So did Christ plead his blood
before the Father in behalf of sinners
and present before him also with the
precious fragrance of his own
righteousness the prayers of penitent
believers. Such was the work of
ministration in the first apartment of
the sanctuary in heaven. Close quote.
But those are the standard responses
that you'll hear from SDAs. Now there is
an assumption undergirling this
discussion that for the sake of argument
I will simply agree with
in the adventist context they are
envisioning a literal building up in
heaven with different rooms and Jesus
moving around in those.
I don't think within the veil I don't
believe within the veil is referring to
a literal curtain in heaven. It's simply
using the earthly sanctuary language to
convey to the original here where Jesus
entered into the presence of God.
This is made clear by simply continuing
to read the book. We're told that where
Jesus entered is an anchor for our soul.
We're told Jesus entered into the
presence of God. Any person familiar
with the Old Testament that heard this
would have known God's presence was only
ever in the most holy place.
Furthermore, the text doesn't say he
simply went behind the veil.
It says he went into the inner place
within the veil.
The Old Testament refers to the inner
place in the context of the sanctuary to
talk about the most holy place.
And the author goes on to great lengths
after these two verses to explain why
Jesus's priesthood is better, many of
which we looked at earlier.
One of those is the difference that
unlike the the Levites where only one
person once a year could enter into
God's presence and not without taking
blood in the new covenant all believers
can enter with boldness through the
single sacrifice of Christ. We have
direct access to the presence of God.
This then gets into Eucharistic theology
and lots of other fun stuff. But the
point being it is very obviously
referring to where only the high priest
could go. It's saying Jesus as a high
priest entered into where the high
priest could go, but he did so after the
order of MelkiseDC, not Aaron. And then
he goes on to explain why Melkisedcian
is greater and superior to ironic,
which perfectly segus into him
explaining all of those things.
The only place in the Old Testament
where it refers to where the high priest
entered within the veil, it always
refers to the day of atonement which
referred to the most holy place.
So that's one. Within the actual flow of
the narrative, it's clear it's referring
to the heavenly equivalent of the
earthly most holy place. Jesus entered
into God's presence and he is our anchor
for the soul there in the presence of
God the father. Secondly, even if we
assume the SDA mindset of it taking or
it talking about various apartments in a
building,
one of their primary arguments for this
is Hebrews 8:5 where they say it says
what was on earth was an identical copy
of what's in heaven. Only what is in
heaven is at a much larger scale.
Again, if you use this argument, then
God's presence was never in the holy
place, only the most holy.
Yet the author of Hebrews explicitly
states Jesus entered into the presence
of God and does the new uh uh uh and as
the New Testament does elsewhere.
So that argument backfires because
apparently it's only a perfect copy in
so far as the SDA system needs it to be.
But other biblical assessments of
Hebrews 6:19-20 that evidence this is in
reference to the heavenly uh equivalent
of the earthly most holy place.
One is that regarding worship the outer
veil had little significance. It was
that inner veil that had significance in
the mind of the Israelite.
Remember the author didn't just say
Jesus entered behind the veil but into
the inner place. The Old Testament
refers to the inner place within the
context of the sanctuary when talking
about the most holy place.
The chances of the author referring to
the significant one are a lot higher
than simply to say Jesus entered into
the curtain at the tabernacle entrance.
And then two, that inner veil had a
worshipful importance to the Israelite.
So with the focus of the author on the
day of atonement and Jesus's once giving
of himself, it makes far more sense to
recognize that the inner veil is in
focus with its day of atonement role in
focus.
Again, the fundamental issue is that for
Ellen White as well as the SDA system of
theology, they do not understand the two
apartment system being a symbol of this
age and the age to come. A contrast
between Judaism of old and Christianity
of new. two distinct priesthood Aaron's
Melkisedc
for Adventism the two compartments
represent a two-faced ministry of Jesus
and that for 1813 years
he was doing one thing and then in 1844
he entered into the second phase of the
atonement into a different apartment to
begin that phase.
This was not done through exogesis of
the biblical text,
but she would use these phrases
prophetically and within documenting her
visions which allowed her to project her
own viewpoint.
Excuse me.
The outer apartment represented an age
of elementary principles such as meat
and drink, washings, regulations. All
that stuff was waxing old and passing
away, which is what the author tells us
in Hebrews 8:9.
That stuff was ready to vanish away. But
Ellen White thought the outer place
ministry represented the work which
Christ would begin at his ascension.
According to Great Controversy, page
420, a a very warped understanding that
entirely misses the substance and
richness of the text at the behest of
having to prop up this ridiculous 1844
theology
as it pertains to the argument that
Jesus entered in and then exited back to
the first apartment and then went back
into the most holy in 1844.
This may sound clever and like it solves
the problem, but it actually just
creates another one.
The author makes it clear Jesus entered
in one time and sat down.
He didn't enter in and leave to then sit
outside on a throne in a hol in the holy
place and then stand up and move in 1844
to sit down again on a second throne in
the most holy place. But then he's also
seated and dealing with sin.
This is fatuous.
Furthermore, the author says he entered
in once and sat down. this particular
argument would have us to believe he
entered twice.
This is a bad argument and it's probably
why it's hasn't become a majority SDA
view or you know one embraced by the SDA
church as an you know in an official
capacity.
But like I said, I've started to
recently hear a lot more administ
pastors putting this argument forth.
We had a friend or listener who I call
friend
submit a video from their previous
Adventist pastor. People submit all
sorts of videos for us to review and
listen to. And he was putting forth this
theory. And friend, if you see this, the
reason why we never got to that is um no
offense to your former pastor, but man,
some of them are just much better at
getting to the point. Um, and that guy
was just he was just going and going and
going and there just really wasn't much
for us to respond to because it was all
this stuff leading up to this climactic
thing of like 40 minutes, all of it to
get to that. And so I don't think the
audience wants to listen to that for 40
minutes while we just then get to that
single thing. But he was putting forth
this position and this was a video from
two years ago
trying to use Moses as an example to say
Moses had to enter into the temple to
activate it before it could be used. So
to Jesus had to go into the most holy
place to activate the temple in heaven
and then he left to begin working in the
outer apartment. But that only creates
further contradictions. So that is proof
8. Hebrews 6:1 19-20 clearly indicates
that Jesus entered into where only the
high priest could, which was the most
holy place. And he did this at his
ascension, and he only entered one time.
Proof number nine, the SDA
interpretation of Colossians 2:14
refutes 18:44.
You might be thinking, interesting. What
do you mean?
This one is an internal critique
argument
that is examining the SDA system for
consistency.
First, let's read this paricopy.
Colossians 2:13-15.
And you who were dead in your trespasses
in the uncircumcision of your flesh, God
made alive together with him, having
forgiven us all our trespasses.
By cancelelling the record of debt that
stood against us with its legal demands,
this he set aside, nailing it to the
cross.
He disarmed the rulers and authorities
and put them to open shame by triumphing
over them in him. Thus, the reading of
God's holy word.
Now, SDAs typically will cite this from
the King James because of the way it
renders that phrase record of debt. They
need the King James' rendering for their
argument.
It translates it handwriting of
ordinances
in response to people that claim this
verse says the Ten Commandments were
nailed to the cross. something answering
Adventism does not affirm. By the way,
they try and argue that no, Paul is
saying the ceremonial law was nailed to
the cross.
Notice what SDA pioneer Uriah Smith says
in his exposition of this paricopy.
Quote,
we call the one the moral law because it
related to moral duties alone. The other
we call the ceremonial law because it
related wholly to ceremonial
observances.
It is not claimed that the terms moral
law and ceremonial law are found in the
scriptures. But they are convenient
terms to express distinctions which the
scriptures clearly teach. Ah
remember that statement next time an
adventist asks you to you know utilize
the verbatim fallacy.
The scriptures do not use the words
probation, prophetic, millennial, moral,
mental, physical, and a host of other
terms which are exceedingly convenient
to express distinctions recognized in
the Bible and to which no one objects.
We say that Colossians 2:14-17
refers exclusively to the ceremonial
law,
having to the moral law, not the
remotest illusion, whatever. close
quote.
So leading up to this quote, he's
formulating his argument for there being
two laws. God's law, which is the Ten
Commandments, and then Moses's law,
which is the ceremonial law.
And it was the ceremonial law that was
nailed to the cross. Pretty standard SDA
claim. That argument aside, I've dealt
with that elsewhere, and we're doing an
internal critique. This interpretation
backfires on their entire sanctuary
model.
Notice what Leviticus 23:26-28
says. This is laying out the
requirements for all sorts of ceremonial
aspects of the law. I'm going to get a
drink here.
And the Lord spoke to Moses, saying,
"Now on the 10th day of the seventh
month is the day of atonement,
it shall be for you a time of holy
convocation,
and you shall afflict yourselves and
present a food offering to the Lord, and
you shall not do any work on that very
day, for it is a day of atonement to
make atonement for you before the Lord
your God.
Thus, the reading of God's holy word.
So, the day of atonement was a part of
the ceremonial law.
Yet, the SDA church claims the
antityypical day of atonement wasn't the
crucifixion day, but a long period of
time beginning on October 22nd, 1844.
We allegedly live in the day of
atonement period right now. But at the
same time, they tell us Colossians 2
says the ceremonial law was nailed to
the cross, just not the day of
atonement. Apparently,
it'd be far more consistent for them, if
they want to roll with this
interpretation of Colossians 2, to
recognize the crucifixion day as the
true fulfillment of the day of
atonement, where the ceremonial law,
including the day of atonement, was
nailed to the cross and fulfilled
entirely by Christ there on that day.
But they can't have that, of course,
because that would bury 1844 theology.
Again, I don't hold the position that
any laws were nailed to the cross
because that's not what Paul's talking
about as the record of death.
But next time you hear this argument
from an Adventist regarding Colossians 2
only referring to ceremonial law, kindly
remind them that interpretation
backfires on them and creates a massive
contradiction in their system. But
that's proof nine, an internal critique
of how the way they interpret Colossians
2:14 refutes claims about the
antityypical day of atonement.
And last but not least,
proof number 10,
Daniel 8:14.
Daniel 8:14, no matter how many ways
they've tried to twist it, has nothing
to do with 1844 in the start of the
investigative judgment.
Now, we won't be able to exhaustively
drill down on every single aspect and
claim the SDA church makes about this
text, but because of everything else
we've looked at, we will look at a
number of them and point out both
internal inconsistencies within their
own framework as well as textual ones
which are sufficient enough. Like I
said, considering the other, well, 10,
including the bonus proof. First, notice
what Ellen White had to say about this
text.
This is from chapter 23 of the great
controversy titled, "What is the
sanctuary?"
Quote, "The scripture which above all
others had been both the foundation and
central pillar of the Advent faith was
the declaration unto 2,300 days, then
shall the sanctuary be cleansed." Daniel
8:14.
These had been familiar words to all
believers in the Lord's soon coming. By
the lips of thousands was this prophecy
repeated as the watchword of their
faith. All felt that upon the events
therein, foretold, depended their
brightest expectations and most
cherished hopes. These prophetic days
had been shown to terminate in the
autumn of 1844.
In common with the rest of the Christian
world,
Adventists then held that the earth or
some portion of it was the sanctuary.
They understood that the cleansing of
the sanctuary was the purification of
the earth by the fires of the last great
day and that this would take place at
the second advent. Hence the conclusion
that Christ would return to the earth in
1844.
Close quote.
Yeah. It wasn't the rest of the
Christian world that believed that. It
was these sects that sprang up in the
19th century that were all damning
everyone uh you know else for not buying
into their second great awakening fervor
and fanaticism that believed uh you know
that which is then equated with the rest
of the Christian world. But here she's
referring to the general Adventist
Millerite movement and she highlights
how Daniel 8:14 was the central pillar
for that movement.
This is before the birth of the 7th
Adventist movement out of the great
disappointment.
This text then carried the same weight
into the SDA movement because their
theology was built upon William Miller's
foundation.
Speaking about this in his book, Father
Miller's Daughter, notice what Donald
Casebolt points out. Quote, "Miller
claimed that he only used his Bible in a
concordance,
that he had set aside all commentaries,
and that in divinely inspired dreams,
God had commissioned him to proclaim his
15 proofs to the world."
Father Miller's spiritual daughter,
Ellen Harmon,
accepted Miller's self-conception at
face value.
Then she enhanced and disseminated
Miller's system and self-perception,
going so far as to claim that Father
Miller had been prefigured by Elijah,
Elisha, John the Baptist, and that God
had given Miller individualized divine
insight into prophecies that had been
shrouded in mystery for centuries.
Miller's spiritual daughter upon
assuming the prophetic role of God's
special messenger perpetuated this
hagographal conception of Miller.
More importantly, he endorsed his
nonliteral methodology.
As a result, the church that Ellen White
founded retained the vestigial uh
vestigial remains of many of Miller's
purported proofs as well as his
nonliteral methodology. all the while
imagining that Miller's method was
literal and common sense.
Close quote.
And this is exactly correct.
And you'll still see this today with
many Adventists. They think their
movement was raised up by God with
special prophetic insight to the Bible,
namely with regards to Daniel and
Revelation. Insight that no one else but
them has. And it began with William
Miller, who allegedly only used his
Bible in a concordance
with zero outside input, utilizing a
plain literal interpretation of the
Bible.
Oh, and and alleged uh divinely inspired
dreams. Don't forget that
Casebolt rightly recognizes before this
quote earlier in the preface how what
they call a plain literal reading of the
Bible is actually an allegorical
typological historical model,
an abuse of history paired with drawing
out typologies
way too far. inserting those, you know,
those events from history and
allegorizing away certain things in such
a way that allowed him to try and make
all of his 15 proofs fit with scripture.
The point being, when it comes to the
SDA interpretation of Daniel 8:14, this
is the crux upon which their whole
system swings.
That's why we heard what we heard in the
intro.
Despite their pivoting and changing of
what they claim it means over the
decades, it's still built upon William
Miller's faulty handling of scripture
and it's still the central pillar for
the system. Ellen White giving the stamp
of approval on Miller's handling and
treatment of the Bible. Albeit she was
smart enough to recognize that he
clearly was wrong on certain areas,
which is why they had to regroup and try
and come up with new theories.
With that background in mind, we're
going to listen to a clip from Doug
Bachelor regarding this text so you can
hear the 21st century claims about this
text which are not identical to those of
the 19th and 20th centuries. Afterward,
we will examine the text and show why
this has so many holes
it could rightly be called Swiss cheese
theology.
You read in Daniel 7:2, "This beast
power would cast the truth to the
ground. He would think to change times
and laws."
And then you read on in um Daniel
chapter 8, he says, "2,000," let's read
the next verse here. "Because of
transgression
concerning the s the daily sacrifice, an
army was given to the horn to oppose the
daily sacrifices. He cast truth to the
ground. He did all this and he practiced
and he prospered. Then I heard one holy
one speaking to the other holy one who
said to that certain holy one who spoke.
And next verse, how long will be the
vision concerning the daily sacrifices
and the transgression of desolation?
There's a time period given of giving
both the sanctuary and the host to be
trampled underfoot. How is it trampled
underfoot? And the Bible says, "If
you'll turn away your foot from the
Sabbath, trampling on truths."
How long would that happen? For 2,300
days, then the sanctuary will be
cleansed. After 2,300 days, a cleansing
would begin. It's almost like when God
told Adam and Eve, "In the day you eat
thereof, you will die." He actually
said, "In in dying, you will die." You
will begin dying.
There would be a new phase of cleansing
that would take place after 2,300
days.
All right. So, what Doug put forth is
pretty standard fair claims about this
text. It's interesting he points out
Genesis 3. We heard this from Dr. Jud
Lake as well, one of the last times we
responded to him where he tried to where
he was talking about Genesis and he's
like, you could think of it kind of like
an investigative judgment type scene.
That's what Doug is alluding to there.
But what he put forth is a pretty
standard fair claim. Daniel was
allegedly shown a large sweeping view of
human history into the future. And when
Daniel 8 says that truth was cast down
to the ground, it was in reference to
all sorts of truthful doctrines that
were cast down to the ground by the
papacy and were then rediscovered by
various people beginning with the
reformation.
They then attach onto that William
Miller and call him an American reformer
and that he laid the groundwork for the
truth of the sanctuary doctrine that
only SDAs have and is the only entirely
unique doctrine of their movement.
So the truth cast to the ground is
supposedly the truth about the SDA
sanctuary doctrine and Daniel was
supposedly shown that after a certain
period of time the truth of this
doctrine would be rediscovered.
And Doug even tried to work in the
alleged Sabbath truth in there as well.
Something he said earlier in that
lecture is a truth that if one rejects,
God rejects them. In conjunction with
this, prior to that clip, Doug also
claimed that the sanctuary to be
cleansed is allegedly the people of God,
the temple that everyone who is a
believer makes up with Jesus as the
chief cornerstone.
So it went from the earth being the
sanctuary with William Miller to the
sanctuary being a building up in heaven
to then well it's the church the people
of God. It's God cleansing his people
from their sins through sanctification.
So let's look at some of these reasons
and why it is badly flawed.
For starters, this idea that it's some
revived truth that got trampled
underfoot and needed to be restored
conflicts with the organization's own
claims about the teaching. We've looked
at this before, but notice what the
review and herald says regarding their
special present truth message. Quote,
"The very fact that this prophecy of the
three angels messages covers the period
between 1844 and the end of the age
shows conclusively that this three-fold
message is God's special message for us
at this very hour.
Just as surely as we are living between
1844 and the coming of Christ, just so
surely may we know that this three-fold
message of Revelation 14 6-12 is God's
present truth for this present time.
The time for this message is very
definitively fixed to the present
generation.
This prophecy of Revelation 14 6-14
does not and cannot
refer to any proclamation of the gospel
in the days of the apostles, the early
Christian fathers or the reformers of
the 16th, 17th or 18th centuries. It is
strictly a last day message applicable
to those who live just before the return
of Christ. Close quote.
So the teaching of the investigative
judgment is a part of what they call the
everlasting gospel. It is a part of
their three angels messages. Well, here
they tell us that this everlasting
gospel message wasn't preached by the
apostles or anyone before them. It is
strictly a last day message applicable
only to those before the return of
Christ. That includes the message of the
investigative judgment.
So, how was it downtrodden for 2300 days
if before the 2300 days it wasn't even
known, taught, or believed?
It wasn't revived, restored,
rediscovered, anything. It was cut whole
cloth from novelty due to needing to try
and find a new solution to the great
disappointment. Second, they need the
day-toear principle to be valid in order
for their handling of the 2300 number to
be valid. Let's grant that principle as
valid and not rabbit trail off into all
that.
Well, that principle only applies when
the text utilizes the Hebrew or Greek
word day, which is not found in in
Daniel 8:14. You know, I've had adversar
like, well, it obviously means day when
it says evening and morning. That's what
a day is.
I friend, you're not going to make it.
They just assert that it says evening
and morning represents a day. So,
therefore, they can apply the principle
there. No, doesn't work that way. And
lots of historicists that utilize the
deer day principle because Adventists
aren't the only historicists.
These individuals watch this channel and
I'm sure they will comment down below
and can explain why no other
historicists in history arrived at the
conclusion that the SDAs do with this
text. So that's two. The Hebrew word
isn't uh you know the Hebrew word day is
not found in Daniel 8:14. Thirdly, the
2300 days is about when something
ceases, not when something will start or
begin. Notice,
out of one of them came a little horn,
which grew exceedingly great toward the
south, toward the east, and toward the
glorious land. It grew great even to the
host of heaven. And some of the host,
and some of the stars that threw down to
the ground, and trampled on them, it
became great, even as great as the
prince of the host. and the regular
burnt offering was taken away from him
and the place of his sanctuary was
overthrown.
And a host will be given over to it
together with the regular burnt offering
because of transgression and it will
throw truth to the ground and it will
act and prosper. Then I heard a holy one
speaking, and another holy one said to
the one who spoke, "For how long is the
vision concerning the regular burnt
offering, the transgression that makes
desolate, and the giving over of the
sanctuary, and the host to be trampled
underfoot."
And he said to me, "For 2,300 evenings
and mornings, then the sanctuary shall
be restored to its rightful state."
Thus, the reading of God's holy word.
So Daniel sees this vision of this
wicked little horn which threw some of
the stars to the ground and trampled on
them. This wicked little horn then
became great causing the burnt offering
practice to be halted by overthrowing
and desecrating the sanctuary. In doing
so, this wicked little horn prospered
for a select duration of time. Daniel
then hears an angel ask another angel,
"How long will this overthrowing of the
burnt offering practice being
overthrown, you know, be overthrown and
trampled underfoot?
to which the angel responds with the
time frame for 2300 evenings and
mornings.
After that, the sanctuary would return
to its normal practice of offering up
sacrifices again.
This is not a time frame for when
something will start.
It is a time frame for how long this
wicked figure will do wicked things.
And the sanctuary in focus is very
obviously the earthly sanctuary where
sacrifices were taking place, not the
entirety of the earth, not a building in
heaven, the earthly tabernacle.
So without even having to get into
interpreting who the wicked little horn
is, what the stars represent, etc., It
can plainly be deduced from the context
that the time frame and reference to how
long a wicked figure will engage in
wicked behavior before then being cut
off and the original practice that was
halted will remain.
Nothing to do with the church being
cleansed when Jesus enters an
architectural building in heaven and
yada yada. We then have the problem of
the Roman Catholic papacy somehow
defiling heaven which is why more and
more Adventists I think have pivoted off
of this because they claim the wicked
little horn is the Roman papacy and the
text says the figure defiles the
sanctuary
to which they've you know used to claim
was referring to the heavenly sanctuary.
This then led to the obvious question of
how did the papacy defile heaven
in which the new solution presented has
been what the likes of people like Doug
Bachelor claim which is that the
sanctuary in focus is actually the body
of Christ the New Testament church where
God is cleansing the individual believer
of his sins and that's what the the
cleansing in focus is. Now this is not
to say they're saying well no there
isn't actually a building in heaven.
They're just saying that here it's
actually focusing on the sanctuary and
focuses the the new temple of God, the
body of Christ, all the individual
believers. On top of all of this though,
the text says nothing about a judgment
for only professing believers, which is
what the SDA church claims the
investigative judgment is.
Now, I don't agree with him on a lot of
stuff, but Desmond Ford tried putting,
you know, pointing this out in his
massive work on the subject before they
dysfellowshipped him and started
slandering him as some vitriolic
apostate Judas a Scariot. Notice what he
incites.
And for those that do not know, this is
coming from a man that still considered
himself an Adventist, folks. He loved
the SDA church and Adventist. was soft,
cordial, honest, sincere, genuine, and
they tore his name to shreds and
continue to slander him to this day,
despite the fact that he's now deceased.
But Ford still held that this text was
about a judgment event. But notice what
he highlights.
Quote, "The overall message of and
witness of the parallel passages of
Daniel make it quite clear that 8:14 has
to do with the redress of wickedness."
the punishment of those outside of
Christ and the vindication of believers.
The judgment brought to view has the
lost as the focus,
not the people of God. It is the little
horn that is being investigated, not the
suffering saints.
The books enshrine the records of
willful transgressions of Satan's
followers, not the failures of the
worshippers of Yahweh. Similarly,
the judgment of Revelation 14:7 as set
forth by the Daniel quarterly of 1967
is not a judgment of the saints but of
Babylon. This harmonizes with the use of
judgment throughout the apocalypse.
Revelation 14:7 is made clear by the
parallel passages of 6 9-10, 16 4-7,
171, 186-10, 1820, and 1913.
Close quote.
So even if we grant even more to their
position, I'll grant the physical
building in heaven. Let's grant that
it's a judgment that's in focus. Even if
we grant that some judgment event is
occurring in this passage, like Ford
still embraced, he was still able to
recognize that the subject in focus is a
wicked figure, not professing believers,
just like in Revelation 14,
which they had to pivot off of. started
saying, "Well, it's talking about God
coming back to cleanse the earth with
fire and the wicked because there's a
judgment on the wicked, but then it
pivoted to being exclusively about the
righteous." It's the exact opposite.
Revelation 14's all about the wicked.
Now, personally, I think Ford still had
vestigages of a great controversy
worldview that sometimes clouded his
interpretive handling, but at least he
was honest in his assessment.
The book of Mcabes, while not inspired
scripture, it does document history of
what Daniel 8:14 is referring to, and
it's the earthly sanctuary, which was
cleansed during the Makabian revolt
after Antus Epiphies defiled it by
putting a severed pig's head on the
altar of sacrifice. We've talked
elsewhere about all of the SDA church's
claims about this and why it can't that,
you know, they say this can't be what's
in focus, and I've addressed those
there. So, you can go and check those
out for a more exhaustive rundown on
that. The Jewish festival of Hanukkah,
what John 10 calls the feast of
dedication or the feast of lights, is a
celebration of the fulfillment of Daniel
8:14.
And while the Jewish understanding of
something in the Old Testament doesn't
make it the deacto correct
understanding, it's very telling that
this is universally understood by them
to have been fulfilled during the
Makabian revolt. And Hanukkah is a
result of its fulfillment. And John 10
actually tells us that Jesus was present
for this taking place in his day. And
it's interesting that he doesn't correct
them. You know, Adventists will tell you
the text doesn't say he was celebrating.
It just that he was there. Yeah. Well,
it's quite odd that he didn't correct
them. He didn't say something to the
effect of, "Well, what what you're
celebrating is wrong. Why are you
celebrating the fulfillment of Daniel
8:14, what we call Daniel 8:14?" Because
they didn't have chapter and verses like
we do. Why are you celebrating the
fulfillment of Daniel 8:14 when that
won't be fulfilled until 1,800 years
from now?
But that's proof number 10. Daniel 8:14
has so many issues both grammatically
and contextually that no matter how
they've tried to spin it and change
things around, it's only created more
problems.
And then when you factor in all the
other proofs on top of that,
it's clear to see for anyone without a
bias and attachment to this doctrine,
it's not biblical.
That's not even all the proofs. We
didn't look at John 5 where Jesus
speaking about judgment for
condemnation.
He's not talking there about those who
believe will come into no judgment
whatsoever. Well, no, that would create
contradictions with Paul's own words to
the Corinthians, namely that we'll all
stand before. Same with the author of
Hebrews. Contextually, Jesus is talking
about judgment for condemnation.
And he clearly says that believers don't
come into judgment for condemnation
because they've already passed from
death to life.
They've already been judged. Yet the
investigative judgment is a judgment for
condemnation and it's exclusively for
believers.
We didn't even look at how there's no
decree in Ezra 7 to rebuild the city of
Jerusalem.
The city of Jerusalem. Adventist friend,
yes, we know what you are appealing to.
And then when you read the narrative,
no, there's no decree from a Persian
king to rebuild the city of Jerusalem.
We have an article on this on our
website. People can go check it out if
you follow the narrative of the story
line.
It was to rebuild the temple, not the
city.
And then they get stopped because wicked
people try stopping God's people. And
they're halted for a season. And then a
new king comes along and God raises up
two prophets and the two prophets speak
and and God essentially says, "Continue
building and I'll provide for you guys.
Just do what you need to do. I'll take
care of you." They're stopped again by
these wicked people while they're
starting back up.
And they say, "Hey, actually, can you
relay a message to the the new king?
There should be in the archives a former
decree that allowed us to rebuild the
temple, not the city, the temple."
So they do that and then the king says,
"Well, by golly, it is." And hey, for
your troubles, I'm going to give you a
bunch of precious metals and a bunch of
stuff you guys need for worship,
fulfilling God's promise to them. I'll
take care of you guys. And they had
everything they needed to start. And
then you get into Ezra 7 where it's
talking about Ezra entering into the the
law work of God,
but there's no decree to rebuild the
city of Jerusalem. and they're taking
something from a individual that's in
correspondence. It's just the whole
thing is off
yet that is necessary for this teaching
to be true and there are many many more.
The fact that this teaching is entirely
novel to the 19th century should be
caused for concern enough and do not
fall for the twisting of the SDA church
that this doctrine's conception is no
different than any other doctrine of the
reformation.
That is a whole another subject that
that they conflate the reformation with
restoration.
No, no, dude. No.
Remember what we read at the beginning.
This teaching is rooted in the larger
SDA theory of atonement.
It has all sorts of major implications
for their system, which is why Clifford
Goldstein so plainly recognized the
logic. If this teaching falls, the SDA
church is built on a lie.
The investigative judgment requires the
support of alleged visions from Higher
Medson and Ellen White. The idea that
it's plainly there in scripture and no
one saw it until a fringe group of
fanatics with no formal training or
theological prowess discovered it is
another red flag that should cause any
rational person's radar to go off.
But as former SDA General Conference
president put it, GI Butler,
quote, "Our position on the testimonies,
that's the writings of Ellen White, is
like the keystone to the arch. Take that
out and there's no logical stopping
place till all the special truths of the
message are gone." Our enemies and the
master they serve realize this, but some
of our people are so blind that they do
not. Nothing is sure than this.
that the message and the visions belong
together and stand or fall together.
Close quote.
If there is anything that should be
classified as a special truth when it
comes to Adventism, it's the
investigative judgment and the
sanctuary. At least Butler was honest
enough to recognize that without Ellen
White, not just the doctrine, but the
entire structure comes toppling down. I
understand Adventists may genuinely
believe this teaching. I understand that
Adventists may think they can prove it
strictly from the Bible, but it doesn't
change the fact that the context of
scripture drives interpretive
methodology. And when that is employed,
this doctrine collapses to dust. When
one removes the SDA pretext of
approaching the Bible to try and support
an already accepted belief, a pretext,
it's plain to see that the plain
teaching of sacred scripture decimates
this doctrine.
If you're a Christian, the hope is that
you're better equipped now to reach
Adventists with the truth and your love
for the word of God has been
strengthened. If you're an Adventist,
the hope is you'll repent of this
damnable uh demonic doctrine which
distorts the atonement, distorts the
gospel, and uh is essentially
antithetical to the Christian faith. But
may Christ richly bless you in the grace
and peace won by him and his vicarious
death on the cross for sinners.
Hallelujah. Marinatha, until next time,
God bless.
[Music]